quand merci la parlait quand monsieur
jean pierre door merci monsieur le
président de la question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la santé madame la
ministre
notre groupe souhaite aussi remercier
chaleureusement les professionnels de
santé les publics comme les libéraux
pour leur action remarquable lors du
drame de nice madame la ministre je non
il faut je faut-il regretter de sortir
de l'actualité de cet après midi je ne
le pense pas car avant la fin de session
avait une question à vous poser une
question que quand même importante alors
que les négociations houleuses sont en
cours entre l'assurance maladie et les
médecins sur la question des tarifs
moi je souhaite vous interroger sur le
projet de décret visant à encadrer les
placements des caisses des professions
libérales
ce projet de décret sans concertation
avec les élus des caisses inquiète
fortement et c'est pourquoi je voudrais
relayer les préoccupations légitimes des
professionnels libéraux
s'il paraît logique de contrôle et la
pertinence de ses placements
la décision autoritaire de l'état qui
seraient prises voudrais intervenir par
une répartition des placements et elle
est déconnectée des réalités du monde
économique et financier et cela serait
préjudiciable alors ajouter à la
souffrance des actifs des professionnels
libéraux
le malheur de leurs retraités par des
prises de risques inconsidérées cela
semble être une faute
les professionnels libéraux s'inquiètent
de l'inadéquation du cadre légal proposé
au regard de la spécificité des réserves
de ses caisses leur gestion actuelle le
soufre à ce jour d'aucune critique
d'importance alors ma question madame la
ministre et suivantes
il est encore temps d'engager le
dialogue avec les élus des caisses des
professions libérales
donc je vous remercie écoutez les et je
pense que le problème pourrait être
résolu
merci la parole est à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
le président mesdames messieurs les
députés je veux à mon tour salué le
travail remarquable des professionnels
de santé dans les hôpitaux de nice qui
aujourd'hui permettent d'accompagner
ceux qui sont encore blessés et monsieur
le député mesdames et messieurs les
députés je veux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
restent hospitalisés soixante-trois
personnes à nice dont 15 ont encore un
pronostic vital engagé
vous m'interrogez monsieur le député sur
un projet de décret relatifs aux
placements assurée par les caisses de
retraite
il s'agit de rassurer car je suis
certaine que nous partageons la volonté
de garantir un versement assurer des
retraites à l'ensemble des français et
comme à tous les français aux
professionnels libéraux des textes
législatifs et réglementaires existent
déjà
il ne s'agit donc pas d'instaurer un
cadre légal mais de faire évoluer les
règles pour tenir compte de l'évolution
des règles prudentielles en matière de
solvabilité par ailleurs des rapports de
l'inspection générale des finances et de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales appellent à une clarification
des dispositions applicables
contrairement à ce que vous avez indiqué
monsieur le député une concertation est
en cours depuis plusieurs semaines et
les différents organismes sont consultés
un projet de décret a en effet été
élaboré en lien avec le ministère des
finances et de l'économie qui a pour
objectif de stabiliser les règles et de
les adapter aux réalités actuelles
je veux vous dire monsieur le député que
nous tenons compte des observations qui
nous sont faites dans l'intérêt des
retraités actuels et futurs parmi les
professionnels libéraux comme pour
l'ensemble des français
merci madame la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue